[Musique]
Chantal Hébert Michel seoget Véronique
prince bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir la
ministre de responsable de l'immigration
au Québec Christine Frechette s'est
aperçu à quel point ça peut être
difficile des fois dans le monde
politique dans les mains qui te presse
et que le chemin Roxane qu'on le regarde
n'importe quel côté c'est un sujet
complexe on va écouter les deux versions
de Madame Fréchette aujourd'hui sur
fermeture ou pas du chemin Roxane on
revient tout de suite
le chemin Roxane si les fermer il va
simplement s'en recréer un autre
quelques kilomètres plus loin donc ça ne
règle absolument rien que de proposer de
fermer le chemin Roxane
Roxane il faut que ça ferme je l'ai dit
la semaine dernière Roxane basta on en a
assez ce flot incessant de demandeurs
d'asile en qui entre de manière
régulière irrégulière
donc Chantal ça sert à rien de le fermer
mais il faut que ça ferme autrement dit
c'est rien de le fermer mais on voudrait
pas qu'il y a des gens qui passent et un
jour que qu'on règle le problème Chantal
bon alors
entendons-nous d'abord une maladie de
presse par définition ce prêtre rarement
à la complexité c'est pour ça que vous
faites ce genre d'émission et des
entrevues qui sont plus longues mais
ensuite il y a une déclaration où on
parle au propre c'est à dire fermer un
chemin et l'autre où on parle aux figuré
c'est à dire mettre fin à une situation
qui perdure et qui devra un jour trouver
un règlement c'est pas autant le chemin
physique sur la carte donc il est
question quand on dit fermer le chemin
Roxane c'est boucher le trou dans
l'entente des tiers pays sur qui fait
qu'il y a un chemin Roxane qui pourrait
s'appeler autrement sur une carte
géographique mais qui
explique bien résume bien en fait la
complexité de cette histoire-là c'est
que le chemin physique quand même qu'on
met une barrière ils vont passer à côté
là c'est ce que la ministre disait le
matin ce matin en fait oui
deux choses différentes qui sont très
toutes les deux le seul problème c'est
que le premier ministre aime plus qu'on
utilise la deuxième version que la
première mais à la fin c'est un affaire
Canado américain c'est l'entente sur le
tiers pays sûr
et aux États-Unis ce n'est pas une
priorité le chemin Roxane qu'est-ce que
vous voulez quand vous avez sur la
frontière sud des États-Unis les mauvais
mois plus de 200 000 entrées illégales
Roxane ça a l'air tout petit et quand on
pensait devenir
ottawaiden sur l'immigration il y a
d'autres priorités c'est ça
Véronique donc oui des gens qui suivent
bien comme Chantal et Michel peuvent
réconcilier mais évidemment il y a eu
quand même un petit moment plus
difficile pour un fléchettes qui a vu
que
il y avait des formules qu'il fallait
garder parfois pour pas sembler
contredire le patron là effectivement
puis le gouvernement le logo trouvait
qu'il y avait eu un bon début de semaine
parce que François Legault c'était porté
comme défenseur du Québec justement
devant la nomination controversée
d'amiral el ghawahabi donc je trouvais
que ça allait quand même bien mais c'est
jamais fini tant que c'est fini comme on
dit puis des fois les balles arrivent du
champ gauche on les voit pas venir même
si ça fait des semaines pourtant que le
Parti québécois répète qu'il faut fermer
chemin Roxane aujourd'hui effectivement
les violons paraissaient pas tellement
accordé mais en même temps pour
n'importe quelle partie politique
de dire faut fermer le chemin Roxane ils
savent que c'est du côté de l'opinion
publique mais ça va vous très bien tous
les parties que c'est pas aussi simple
que ça que c'est une question très
complexe qu'est-ce que ça veut dire le
fermer on peut pas mettre de mur alors
quand Christine Frechette dit vont
passer par d'autres effectivement ça
peut être le cas donc fermez sa veut
dire quoi exactement dans la négociation
sur l'entente des pays sûrs mais ça les
partis politiques le définissent pas
nécessairement parce que c'est plus
populaire de dire on ferme le chemin
Roxane c'est ce qu'on veut et si elle
avait et c'est ça en deux mots elle le
dit on veut régler le faire du chemin
Roxane mais c'est pas un le ferment
physiquement qu'on va régler le chemin
Roxane c'est ça que qu'on peut on a
réconcilier pour les gens qui nous
écoutent ce qui paraît vraiment
contradictoire je veux notre collègue
Gérald Fillon dans un dans un balado
interviewer l'ancien ministre des
Finances monsieur l'État et
Monsieur létal qui s'ouvre et qui dit
savez-vous on est allés trop vite
notamment dans les coupures dans les
compressions dans le stérilité notamment
dans le secteur de
on écoute
donc c'est comme ça qu'on a
atteint nos cibles budgétaire donc c'est
comme ça que quand on a réduit les
effectifs
ne remplaçant pas ce qui quittait et
c'est ça que dans un dans un réseau
comme celui de l'éducation à causé
beaucoup de difficultés
je l'admets c'était à refaire je pense
que un éducation on aurait été un peu
plus un peu plus clément
quand Carlos parle j'écoute et je suis
d'accord avec lui qu'il faut reconnaître
avec les données qu'on a aujourd'hui que
si c'est à refaire nous aurions dû faire
différemment nous ferions différemment
alors Véronique et nos collègues LCL
avec Paul monsieur barrette qui a dit la
même chose moi on est allé trop vite en
santé aussi donc là
les langues se délient puis c'est comme
si on voulait mettre de côté dans le
passé cette histoire oui je me rappelle
quand il était parti Gaétan Barrette
avait annoncé dans sa conférence de
presse de départ qu'il n'aurait jamais
mis fin au programme de fécondation in
vitro la gratuité et puis d'ailleurs le
gouvernement le goût leur amené j'ai
souvent entendu aussi des libéraux qui
disaient c'est qu'on avait modulé les
tarifs de garderie en fonction du revenu
des parents mais finalement on n'aurait
jamais dû faire ça parce que ça nous a
pas rapporté l'argent espéré ça dérangé
beaucoup beaucoup de parents ça crée des
remous dans le système des garderies
donc on voit effectivement qu'ils ont
plusieurs regrets mais en même temps
dans un parti politique c'est une équipe
il y a un chef on suit la ligne de
partie même si on n'est pas tout le
temps d'accord ceux qui suis pas
d'accord démissionne alors si Carlos
letter l'avait pas fait à ce moment-là
c'est parce qu'il y croyait finalement
oui et lui et le Martin quateux
président du Conseil du Trésor et le
Premier ministre c'est le trio qui
s'occupait tout ça Michel c'est
mieux vaut tard que jamais je suis
content de voir qu'il a des remords en
même temps c'est pas comme si le
gouvernement de l'époque ne savait pas
que ça causait des problèmes il y avait
des chaînes humaines de parents devant
les autres devant les les écoles tout le
monde leur disait écoutez le système est
Abou est à bout de force on a des et on
sentait devenir des pénuries
personnelles qui sont encore plus
grandes aujourd'hui moins ça à tenir
déjà
gentil de dire bon ce qu'il y avait si
on avait su on n'aurait pas fait ça mais
ils ont eu tous les signaux d'alarme
nécessaire pour comprendre qu'il fallait
pas faire ça et ils les ont ignoré
Chantal et si seulement c'était le passé
et là on pourrait dire je regrette le
passé mais la vérité c'est que le
présent
se vit à cause du passé et quelque part
politiquement il y a un cadeau de Noël
en février pour Bernard drinville
là-dedans et pour Christian Dubé parce
que en clair ce que des ministres
seniors du gouvernement de Philippe
Couillard nous disent c'est vous voyez
les dégâts dans lesquels on est
aujourd'hui en santé et en éducation ben
c'est nous et c'est notre gestion et je
vous dirai que tous ces aveux là vont
pas se perdre au fil des prochaines
années on a un extrait je crois de
Monsieur drinville
qu'on peut passer justement réaction à
ce qu'a dit Monsieur l'État
monsieur Tanguy vient de déclarer chef
du Parti libéral vient de déclarer qu'il
aurait fait les choses différemment
c'est bien que le PLQ reconnaît ses
erreurs mais ça n'efface pas les dégâts
infligés à notre système et pour
lesquels on ressent encore les effets
aujourd'hui
alors c'est comme si vous avez entendu
et je ne l'avais pas entendu je me
disais je lui ai enlevé et vice-versa
dans son cas les mots de la bouche mais
c'est un fait il y a raison on peut pas
juste dire on aurait dû faire
différemment et puis s'en aller en
sifflant et en disant et nous on pense
qu'on devrait gouverner le Québec parce
qu'on est bon les libéraux répondrai oui
effectivement on a dû sûrement on est
allé trop vite il le dit tous mais ils
sont arrivés puis résultat il y a eu
quand même des surplus de 7 milliards
Véronique oui c'est ça c'est quand même
ça a donné une grosse marge de manœuvre
à François Legault lorsqu'il est arrivé
en poste pour mettre en place vraiment
son propre programme puis ça y a fait un
bon coussin aussi le moment d'affronter
la pandémie alors tout n'est pas noir
mais effectivement peut-être que dans
certains secteurs ils sont allés trop
vite mais ça c'est quand même propre aux
gouvernements majoritaires les deux
premières années tu te dépêches à mettre
en place des politiques qui vont pas
plaire parce que les deux années
suivantes c'est qu'il faut que tu
prépares ta réélection donc peut-être
qu'il y a eu un espèce d'empressement
parce qu'il y avait des agences de
notation aussi à New York nous dit-on
qui qui voulait décoter le Québec mais
c'est en presse-ma-là est-ce qu'ils ont
bien pris le temps de faire l'analyse
pourtant il y avait un comité qui avait
été créé par Martin quateux justement
pour pour la révision des programmes et
s'assurer qu'on faisait les bonnes
choses il y avait beaucoup de cartésien
et peut-être qu'il manquait un peu de il
manquait un peu de sensibilité terrain
en fait
le but de l'État québécois ce n'est pas
de faire des surplus de 7 milliards
c'est d'assurer certaines fonctions
essentielles parmi lesquelles il y a
l'éducation la santé la justice etc un
moment donné il y a quelqu'un qui a
perdu la mission essentielle de l'État
québécois dans ce gouvernement c'est
évident mais ça revient quand même à
l'idée que se faisait Philippe Couillard
et je vous dis ça parce que c'est lui
qui me l'avait dit comment il voyait ça
être au Conseil des ministres et il
était pas encore revenu en politique à
ce moment-là mais il m'avait dit c'est
un peu comme gérer un conseil
d'administration j'aurais dû à l'époque
faire plus attention à cette vision qui
avait Philippe Couillard de son futur
rôle de premier ministre parce qu'il a
géré comme s'il était président d'un
conseil d'administration et qui donc
présente aux actionnaires ça c'est nous
les électeurs une feuille où il y a
beaucoup de retombées le problème c'est
que le Québec c'est pas une compagnie on
n'est pas des actionnaires et on
hypothèque l'avenir
voilà Helga el ghaouabi suite et fin je
pense que tout le monde s'entend pour
dire suite et fin vous allez entendre
monsieur Legault qui est d'une certaine
façon tourne la page aussi ce Blanchère
avait décidé de le rencontrer hier a
décidé de parler aujourd'hui alors
Monsieur Blanchet et Monsieur Legros
puis on revient
il me paraît claire et sans équivoque
suite à cette rencontre
que Madame Amira el ghaouabi ne peut pas
occuper la fonction pour laquelle Justin
Trudeau la désigner le Premier ministre
doit renoncer non seulement à la
nomination mais à la création même d'un
tel poste
monsieur Truteau persiste à défendre une
mauvaise décision il va vivre avec cette
décision là je pense que tout était dit
je pense que tout a été dit Véronique
tour de table là-dessus
monsieur Trudeau manifestement ne
changera pas à court terme d'avis les
l'autre visions non plus puis voilà
oui mais en même temps ça va être
intéressant de voir comment Québec
soldat va se positionner parce qu'ils
sont censés rencontrer Madame el
garouabi puis sont les derniers en fait
à la rencontre le Bloc québécois a
décidé finalement de suivre ce que le
Québec a fait c'est-à-dire la motion ne
pas aller à l'encontre de la motion où
on demandait justement de la démettre de
ses fonctions il y a eu un signal clair
de Québec le Bloc québécois répondait à
ce signal là finalement il y a Québec
soldat qui s'est abstenu de voter sur la
motion donc de leur côté ils ont un
conseil national qui s'en vient à peu
près une semaine puis je sais pas s'ils
vont rencontrer Madame elgaouabi avant
mais c'est une question dont ils
pourront pas se débarrasser
en même temps
la réalité c'est Monsieur Blanchet a
fait ses petites affaires il est allé la
rencontrer
voter sur une motion comme l'assemblée
et qu'elle n'a pas encore pu parler
c'est pas une façon de fonctionner
l'Assemblée nationale doit pas être un
tribunal c'est pas ça qu'elle fait la
loi et donc au delà de au-delà de la
politique qui connaît quand même donner
la chance à cette personne-là de
s'expliquer et après ça ce monsieur
Blanchet pas satisfait des explications
il fait ce qui a fait ce matin en disant
elle ne devrait pas être dans son poste
et là la balle est dans le cadre de
Monsieur Trudeau qui doit dire bon ben
il y a quand même quelques parties à la
Chambre des communes qui dit on va avoir
un problème avec cette histoire oui mais
peu importe les explications qu'elle
aurait pu donner à Monsieur Blanchet
compte tenu des déclarations passées il
aurait été étonnant que le bloc dise
après le gouvernement du Québec
savez-vous on pense que elle peut rester
elle va elle va pouvoir pouvoir être en
mesure de jeter des ponts avec toutes
les communautés donc ça aurait été
étonnant parce que
j'entends ce que vous dites et puis vous
l'avez bien souligné depuis qu'on parle
de ça depuis quelques jours de
condamnations avant même de rencontrer
les gens Chantal où vous en êtes dans
tout ça
à me demander
si le bureau de Justin Trudeau et là je
vais poser une question et la réponse
est évidente si on avait dit au bureau
de Justin Trudeau on a une excellente
candidate pour un poste le problème
c'est qu'elle a déjà twitté que l'idée
que les autochtones ont été opprimés par
la colonisation et autres ça l'a fait
vomir tellement trouve que c'est une
idée pas recevable je pense pas que
Monsieur Trudeau le renommé c'est un peu
là-dedans qui s'est embarqué je reste
avec plein de questions sur comment
est-ce que le bureau du premier ministre
fait ses vérifications avant de faire
des nominations
j'ai l'impression qu'elle a intérêt à
profiter des rencontres qu'elle va avoir
quelques-unes d'ici Pablo Rodriguez
Québec solidaire parce qu'après ça au
Québec il y a un collègue du globe qui
l'écrit aujourd'hui qu'on regarde whisky
son rôle il semble devoir être de
prêcher au converti oui parce que pour
les autres au Québec je pense que la
porte est fermée n'est-ce pas il y aura
pas de je pense pas qu'ils vont
l'inviter à parler au Conseil National
de Québec solidaire donc peut-être que
le dénouement ultime c'est qu'elle va
elle-même juger qu'elle n'a pas
l'autorité morale en tout cas elle a pas
les le contexte n'est pas favorable un
dialogue avec toutes les communautés qui
c'est Michel Véronique la balle est dans
son camp effectivement où le camp de
Justin Trudeau c'est ce qu'on juge à
Québec mais on veut pas en rajouter pour
pas avoir l'art non plus de faire de la
récupération politique là-dessus puis
d'essayer de jouer la carte payante
je suis très d'accord avec Chantal quel
genre devait être une il faut ces
gens-là Ottawa pourtant il y a une
machine pour faire ça mais une fois que
cela existe au Premier ministre de la
démettre ce qui pense qu'elle ne peut
pas faire le travail puis de tout
évidence il y a beaucoup de gens qui
pensent
très bien merci combien je sais c'est
pas mal tout merci beaucoup Chantal
Michel C Véronique bonne soirée on se
retrouve très bientôt au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI